what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today I want to take a close
look at the strongest demon moon and
strongest demon slayer in komatsuna
Yaiba in the newest chapter chapter 174
we found out about upper moon ones
extremely interesting backstory so I'll
be covering that in this video along
with other relevant information if you
want to see more videos about the new
chapters of demon slayer make sure to
smash that like button to let me know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell for more demon
slayer content on this channel leave
suggestions for future videos you would
like to see in the comments and if that
ain't enough demon slayer greatness for
you follow us on instagram and twitter
at anime uproar for more including
crucial anime updates there obviously
will be manga spoilers in this video now
without further ado let's jump into it
in the previous chapters arguably our
strongest pillars the rock pillar the
wind pillar and the mist pillar were
fighting together against the strongest
demon moon who goes by the name kakushi
bow before becoming a demon he was a
demon surnamed Michi katsu Sugi Kuni he
is action ancestor of the mist pillar mu
Ichiro tokoto kakushi bow uses breath of
the moon to fight he has six eyes on his
face I could create many more with his
flesh he even makes a sword out of his
flesh that has many eyes on it the sword
increases his field of vision and it can
be reshaped and repaired if broken his
breath of the Moon slashes travel
through the air at the target and
they're accompanied by many smaller
crescent moon blades that are constantly
spinning and changing insides these
crescent blades increase his attack
power and make his attacks unpredictable
and thus harder to dodge because he's a
demon he has been able to live for
around half a millennia aka 500 years
this means that he has had all that time
to gain experience and improve his
skills we don't even need to get into
the insane regeneration abilities that
regular demons have let alone those I'm
an upper Moon even among upper moon
demons we are told that upper rank one
can't be compared to any of the rest
he is leagues ahead of that in power for
all these reasons he has been beating
three of the most powerful pillars for
many chapters
however in Chapter one 273 our pillars
managed to turn the tide against the
Moon breather gill made the blind rock
pillar developed the ability to sense
the demon's pulse and was able to form a
your image of him through his senses Mui
cheeto also developed the ability to see
through people's flesh like demon moon
Duan can do they launched a combined
attacking Guillaume a man just take off
kuku she bows arm while mu Ichiro sneaks
it and stabs him with his sword then
while sana me and Guillaume a are
distracting him ganya who absorbed some
of kuku she bows powers by eating his
flesh shoots at coco she bow with his
demon enhanced gun just as tonsure was
told kenya in the past the weakest
person has the greatest potential since
an opponent can only focus on so many
enemies at a time he will focus more on
strong opponents and pay less attention
to someone who they think is weak so the
weak person can take advantage of that
and open a way to victory this is
exactly what ganga does kenya proceeds
to shoot a cuckoo she bow and gets his
homing missile asked bullets into his
body because kenya absorbed coca she
bows powers he is able to use blood
demon arts so that the bullets that
enter kakushi bow can grow into trees
that trap him
I joked in my 12 demon moons and their
powers explained video that cuckoo Sheba
was so overpowered that I wouldn't even
be surprised if he had hoshi rama cells
and this makes it seem like he actually
does after all if kenya used cuckoo she
bowls flesh to unleash these tree powers
it would make sense that hakushi bow can
do it too then like a jinchuriki cuckoo
she bow is stopped by the hashira ma
asked wood-style binding then as the
strong pillars including gill may
approach him it seems like hakushi bow
finally experiences fear he finally
feels like he might lose this match for
the first time his life feels threatened
as the core of his body freezes up this
feeling reminds him of what happened 400
years ago suggesting that it's been 400
years since someone has pushed him this
much
then we jumped an extremely interesting
and insightful flashback it happened on
the night of a red moon and if there's a
red moon you know something's about to
go down
on this night Coco Chabot saw his aged
and decrepit younger twin brother
yo Deecee tsuki Kuni yo Deecee is the
breath of the sun user and he appears to
be the one that cornered and almost
defeated Mouzon in the past however
Mouzon managed to escape and survive in
his prime you could argue that this
breath of the sun' user was the
strongest fighter in all of demon slayer
at least so far however at this point
this breadth of the
user looks really old in fact kakushi
bow says that it's been over 60 years
since he last met his younger brother
who had stayed human and at this point
must be older than 80 Fukushima thinks
it's impossible that he's still alive
since he has the mark and everyone who
has one of those is supposed to die
before they turn 25 years old yo Deecee
simply gives his sympathies to his older
brother and cries cuckoo Shippo is
surprised that the old and ugly figure
of his little brother is showing pity
for him interestingly enough though
cuckoo Shiva holds no anger towards his
law brother because his little stoic
brother was usually so emotionless the
fact that he is now shedding tears
causes something to well up inside Coco
Chabot for the first time since he was
born
he is confused at his own feelings he
decides he has to kill this human part
of himself by killing this old man of
brittle flesh who appears to be long
past his prime then as the fight begins
yo Deecee gets completely serious the
sentimentality disappears before he even
attacks his presence alone makes hakushi
bow feel as if rocks had come to rest on
both shoulders as he explains the weight
of the air increased due to the old
man's aura of intimidation Coco she will
cease absolutely no opening and his low
brother stands your Ichi gives his
brother the courtesy of letting him know
he's going to start his attack and then
he cuts Coco she bows neck before he can
even react it's clear that even though
he's old yo Deecee
just liked Angelo's father was advanced
as a fire God can still show
unbelievable stamina given the
circumstances kakushi beau reveals that
he's jealous of his brother and he's
always been he was always a special one
he is marked but he lived long he is old
but his technique has speed and power
that is no different from when he was in
his prime Kaku Shiva has always been
jealous because his brother alone seems
to be outside the laws of the world and
he receives the favor of the gods upon
himself
for these reasons he hates him and wants
to kill him nevertheless he was sure
that this old man's next attack would
chop off his head and kill him he points
out that his little brother sword
technique even pressed Mouzon saying
that it was nothing less than godly he
feels like his insides might burst
because the feet seems inevitable he
knows he is completely outclassed but
that final blow never came his brother
like a true boss died standing upright
he fought with amazing overwhelming
skills right up to the second he died
from old age that is Kaku Shabazz
backstory
he was the twin brother of the breath of
the Sun user that upset moves on so much
and pretty much gave him PTSD he was
jealous of his brothers skills and
couldn't even beat him after he turned
into a demon and after his brother
became an old man only the death of his
brother his human mortality saved
Kakashi Bo from death that day although
arguably yo Deecee could have finished
him off with the first slash so I can't
help but wonder if he couldn't bring
himself to kill his brother even though
he was a demon obviously the situations
are completely different but to an
extent the Sun breath user must have
felt something like what tan Jiro feels
towards nez Zuko even if your siblings
become demons they're still your
siblings so it seems that after 400
years kikuchi bo again finds himself in
a situation where it seems like he is
about to die however this time there is
no chance of his four enemies just
dropping dead from old age we'll have to
wait and see what happens but it
wouldn't surprise me if the strongest
demon moon has some more tricks up his
sleeves but let me know what you think
in the comments the theory that Kakashi
Bo was twin brothers with the breath of
the Sun user did turn out to be correct
but man what a powerful old dude that
was yo Deecee has to be included in all
future videos about strong and epic old
guys in anime and that is it for today's
video make sure to smash that like
button if you enjoyed it if you haven't
be sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you get notified
when future Demon Slayer vids drop I'm
glad that the secret behind the
strongest upper moons past has finally
been revealed and with it so has the
secret behind the overpowered breath of
the Sun user I'm absolutely loving demon
slayer right now and I gotta say it's
already one of my favorite series of all
time I can't wait to see what happens
next and you can also stay up to date on
crucial news by following us on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar a big
thank you goes out to our patrons over
on patreon who help make videos like
this one possible I especially want to
thank our pro hero to your patrons the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius angel Cruz
Steelers and Pablo Pablo and are the one
tier patrons the ones who stay atop all
clans baby ray
a 17mm TP Steven Ingrid ah a Lola autumn
Mary Mac 239 makoto-kun keel on and
elrico dames and the patrons who
transcend greatness itself Regan
Harrison and Lord knocks on door the
chosen few who have been acknowledged by
Lord we go himself if you enjoy our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com anime uproar and becoming
a patron today for as little as $1 if
you do so you'll get your name featured
in future videos longside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patient only
discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin and
just so you guys know in addition to
patreon you can now join the YouTube
channel and support us that way and
you'll get the same great rewards and
until next time see you space cowboy
[Music]